it is the garden of england but how can
anything bloom in this the village
greens of kent haven't been that color
for weeks
roger and joyce field helped to maintain
the flower beds and planters in the
village of lye but even before this
hosepipe ban they were already resigned
to losing them it wouldn't be a tragedy
as such but it would be a shame
and it would be um another sort of nail
in the coffin of
a village life i can't remember last
time now when we really what i call
really had rain it must have been about
april i really can't remember
and for those who rely on the green
fingered here things are now even harder
as a business this garden center outside
tunbridge is exempt from the
restrictions but its customers aren't
and having seen sales halve over the
summer they fear they'll dry up even
further it is a quiet time but it's
really quiet right now because putting a
plant into the ground today
is a challenge i mean physically getting
out in the garden you've got to be
conscious of sunburn and all those
things as well
anyone who breaks the hosepipe ban could
be fined up to a thousand pounds but it
seems there are few here willing to do
as southeast water asks and grass up any
neighbours breaking the rules will you
be snitching on any neighbors if you're
no i will not
i think that's dreadful
i wouldn't go out my way to grass
someone in but i am aware of the fact
that the rule falls for everyone i've
just come through a traffic jam that's
got a burst pipe
going running down the road and there's
nobody working on it so
you sort of think to yourself if it's
that important then the leaks as
unprecedented as these conditions are
people here know they may have to get
used to them but that means not just
reducing how much water we use there's
also a real need for us as a society to
improve how water is collected and
stored for the future
but when pushed by sky news water
regulator of refused to pin blame on
providers despite three billion liters
lost through leakage every day
nationwide what we're doing seeing on
demand reduction and what we're seeing
on leakage reduction needs to go a lot
further we absolutely accept that with
the target for the sector's reduced
leaks by 50 that suggests you recognize
there has been a failure no what i
recognize is there's quite a long way to
go these networks are big and they're
complicated
and so for now the onus is on
householders to maintain water supplies
where the south of england has gone by
imposing restrictions other parts are
sure to follow iva bennett sky news kent